c'est l'histoire d'un éléphant une
histoire d'agnès de lestrade illustré
par guillaume plantevin aux éditions
sarbacane
c'est l'histoire d'un éléphant qui
n'était pas content du tout ce qu'il a
mal dormi à cause d'une chauve-souris
café grande frange toute la nuit
pile au dessus de son lit au matin
l'éléphant de très mauvaise humeur
croiser son voisin le singe sans
commencement avant que je te crois que
le popotin cria l'éléphant et le singe
qui est tout riquiqui à côté de
l'éléphant s'enfuit en courant
c'est l'histoire d'un singe qui n'est
pas content à cause d'un éléphant qui a
mal dormi à cause d'une chauve-souris
qui a fait 30 range toute la nuit pile
au dessus de son lit sur le chemin le
singe croiser un serpent si j'étais toi
je disparaîtrai je suis très très énervé
et je risque de te transformer en sac à
main pour ma fiancée et le serpent qui
est beaucoup plus riquiqui que le singe
fils sous un rocher sans se retourner
c'est l'histoire d'un serpent qui n'est
pas content à cause d'un singe qui a eu
peur d'un éléphant qui a mal dormi à
cause d'une chauve-souris qui affiche
chronique rouge toute la nuit
pile au dessus de son lit sur son chemin
il croise une souris je te préviens
j'ai très faim si tu ne disparaît pas
immédiatement goethe avalerait toit
était dix sont gonflés et la souris
s'enfuit en criant comme une souris qui
a très peur d'un serpent et c'est comme
ça qu'elle tombe sur l'éléphant celui
qui n'était pas content parce qu'il
n'avait pas dormi de la nuit à cause
d'une chauve-souris enfin tu connais la
suite d'accords une souris c'est tout
riquiqui à côté d'un éléphant mais les
éléphants très peur des souris qui
pourrait rentrer dans leurs trompes et
les étouffer en un rien de temps alors
la souris fille juste et ça a suffi à
faire fuir l'éléphant qui parti en
courant s'enfermer dans sa maison c'est
l'histoire d'une souris très très fier
d'avoir fait peur à l'éléphant et qui
s'en va de ce pas raconter ses prouesses
à sa meilleure amie la chauve souris
celle là même qui avait fait crunch
crunch bla bla bla bla bla et les deux
copines ri tellement pile au dessus du
lit de l'éléphant que
si tu veux connaître la suite de
l'histoire
relis là